Speaker 1: Let's go next to Janik from Las
Vegas.
Yannick, how's Vegas these days?
Speaker 5: David Pakman can you hear me?
I can.
OK, I have one of those fears.
I always see how when the connection is bad,
how much it upsets.
Speaker 1: It saddens me.
Yeah, but no, our connection is solid right
now.
Speaker 5: So I've got a lighthearted kind
of funny question for you.
So I'm a financial advisor.
I have some clients who I don't want to say
anything too specific.
But imagine some of the craziest people you
see on your show.
Like they are cuckoo for cocoa puffs.
Yeah, but I help them manage their money.
OK, so some of my friends like joke around
and are like, You're basically a Candace Owens
of wealth management.
So.
My question is is like.
What what's your opinion on me, you know,
having those clients inevitably
Speaker 1: listen, if a financial adviser
is so attached to not helping people whose
political views are at odds with their own?
Well, it's up to you to decide.
I'm only going to manage money for progressives
like you could do that.
I don't have any kind of opinion on that.
I mean, I think, you know, there's lots of
jobs where, I mean, could a mechanic say,
we only fix cars for progressives like sure,
I could.
But at a certain point, it's sort of like,
what are we trying to do?
And if your goal is simply like, OK, let me
build my business as an adviser and just help
as many people as possible, even if some of
those people will take their gains and donate
it to causes I don't want.
It's ultimately your call.
I don't have any view on the right.
Speaker 5: I'm going to tell him, you said
that.
And also funny.
No kind of not funny.
During the last election, I talked to a lot
of people who were so deluded by this.
You know, Joe Biden is a communist.
Joe, you know, he's going to crash the market.
And I explained to them, like, listen, every
article I'm reading that's coming out is basically
saying, like, this guy's policies are not
going to be much different than Trump anyway.
And these a lot of people, I watched them
sell millions of dollars out of the market
and I'm like,
Speaker 1: Well, Yannick, I'm curious why
you didn't say something else.
What if you told them the truth, which is,
stocks tend to perform better when a Democrat
is president than when a Republican is president
going back to the beginning of the market?
I mean, it's an undeniably accurate statement.
What would they say if you told them that?
Speaker 5: I think I just think if you're
getting into specific facts like that, they're
just going to not believe it essentially.
Speaker 1: So they don't trust you as a financial
advisor.
Speaker 5: I think a lot of people let their
political leanings over affect their investment
decisions.
Speaker 1: Right?
No, I don't.
I don't doubt that.
But I mean, it would just be interesting if
as if presumably they trust you to manage
their money and they go, I'm thinking of selling
everything because a Democrat is going to
win.
If you go, Oh no, no, no, the market does
fine under Democrats, you'd think most people
would be like, Oh, all right, I won't do anything
then, right?
Speaker 5: And I also think it's funny because,
you know, I talk some of my buddies and we're
like, looking back, I wonder, like if I asked
these same people do, like, do I think they'd
be checked into reality that like, Oh, I was
wrong?
Or are they going to find some like, Oh, the
Democrats are, they're rigging the stock market.
So it it's just a funny thing, but I'm going
to get out of here, my brother.
I really appreciate the time.
I'm a massive fan of your show.
So this this was really honors the first time
I ever jumped in the charts.
Speaker 1: So beautiful.
And things are things are OK in Vegas.
I potentially will be back there in a few
weeks for my first.
It's going to be my triumphant return since
the start of the pandemic.
Speaker 5: You know, it's it's good, so I
just moved.
I grew up in Vegas.
I went to school at Georgetown University.
I moved to New Jersey and have been working
there ever since.
And then I just recently moved back to Las
Vegas.
OK, I went independent as an adviser.
The biggest change, like besides that, there's
like kind of everyone wears masks and excuse
me, there's never really been any mask mandates
in Jersey, right, lately.
So I'm kind of getting used to like everyone
here wearing the masks all the time.
But even people here are strapped to the teeth.
And what I mean is the amount of guns that
people have here.
It's it's just such a juxtaposition to what
I was used to in New Jersey at this point.
You know, it's just like seeing people just
open carry at the Albertson's, you know, it's
just it's just a wacky, wacky thing if if
you haven't seen it in a while, you know,
yeah, no
Speaker 1: doubt about it.
All right, Yanek, thank you for the call.
Speaker 5: A real honor.
My brother having
Speaker 1: there is Yannick from Vegas.
Let's take a very short break.
If you're holding, don't hang up because I'm
going right back to the phones in
a moment.